I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
I'm gonna kick this off with a nice and
complicated two-parter for all of you so
with this movie can you each name one
thing that hardcore D and D fans are
going to be real excited to see
represented in this movie but then also
what's something else that you're really
excited for d d newcomers to get to
experience for the first time in the
film there are certain spells that are
used
um a little tiny details that they add
in that only I think only d d players
will catch and I think they did a really
good job with that well uh I would
there's some old friends
nice one there's some old friends in the
movie that people will recognize and
have uh I think a laugh where they're at
and then uh I quite like these odd
little brain walking what are they
called none
The Rock on
okay that's pretty cool there's a couple
of innovations that they allowed
themselves for the making of the movie
that I think will will take a lot of the
DND uh Crowd by surprise but but with
respect you know like they went through
all the channels before you know
inventing their own everyone loves a
mimic and that's in the trailer yeah so
like there you go everyone everyone
loves me because everyone hates I've
I've grown a lit I've done like a lot of
research over the years I've never
actually played myself which is very
disappointing but I've watched like a
million videos and the first thing that
I ever got obsessed with because I like
horror and creatures is is the mimic and
what it is but you're so obsessed with
it why didn't you why haven't you played
I don't this is terrible but I'm afraid
to play things that I am afraid that I'm
not good enough at so I I mean actually
I could throw that ques I was gonna save
a little uh DND 101 for all of you but
for someone in my shoes who has never
played and might be intimidated to jump
in with people who who know a
significant amount
I played with my nephews played for uh
he's 13 he's played for like four years
and he writes campaigns and he plays
every week with the same crew of kids
that he's played with and he has these
two incredible dungeon Masters that that
lead them in all of their uh you know
all of their games or whatever no I
think really what it takes is a good
leader a good dungeon master that's
going to lead you on the story they're
like the narrator they're like um what's
his name and Princess Bride is reading
the story to Fred Savage and um and then
it just takes creativity and Imagination
it takes a good improv mind so I always
say it's like an improv it's yes and so
it's like and you're thrown on uh
whatever the top of the parapet and you
have a something something and what are
you gonna do and it's you don't argue
with it you just say yes Aunt great and
I'll do that and you keep it on moving
keep on moving so it's I played with my
parents my father's 82 my mom's 76 and
we were by two and a half hours in uh we
had to end it because it was already 11
pm we needed to leave but the all it was
was joy and creativity and sparking fun
and all that you'll screw up all sorts
of ways and it doesn't matter because
you start right back up again and you
start another game so it doesn't matter
at all the best thing about the game is
you're not doing it right unless you get
it wrong but that's how it works I feel
like I need to embrace that more in
every area of my life
for the two of you is there anything
that you're really excited for hardcore
DND fans to get to experience in this
film what do you think I was gonna send
it to you yeah I think there's so many
uh there's so many different nods to the
different species that exist in faerun
the ericokra is one I think that's in
the trailer that's how you say that
right Sophia
she acts like she doesn't know more than
she she does I always go to her for
reference uh the DND lore but then she
leaves me hanging but sometimes it's
just hard to quell Sofia's excitement
you know but there's also like the like
the the the feline born creatures which
names escaping the tabaxia oh wait is
that the fish one that is the no this is
yeah
I'm mad about the fish I know the fish
is great gently there's a big fish it's
one of those deep sea fishes too with
the external uh you know uh pineal glass
about with practical effects so like oh
it all feels so real and there's an
Integrity to the movie but there was
also the fact that I was warned that I
could lose an arm to this mechanical
fish if I did not get my timing right
like it could probably have the force to
take my arm there's a mechanical fish
yeah I love hearing big practical
effects oh really practical effects
deadly practical effects yeah I mean
they are robots it continues to be two
arms so you know I wrangled the fish
successfully clearly you had a lot of
wonderful people on set with your crew
wise to keep you nice and safe Chris
I'll go to you now and I'll I'll warn
you because this question kind of comes
from some speculation that I've seen
online it's something I've been curious
about too so based on the trailer we
know that there's an in-world adventure
that we're all going to get to go on but
I've been wondering is there anything in
the movie that's kind of reflective of
the feeling of playing the game because
a lot of people have looked at your
character and the fact that he gives
narration in the trailer and they're
thinking that he's gonna feel a little
like a DM in this experience really the
extent of it it should be said that the
movie is not about people playing the
game and I think that's really important
this is not some sort of meta take on
the the story these are about people
living within the world of Dungeons and
Dragons going on an adventure with the
with all of the Spells and all of the
rules that kind of people have to buy to
abide by but as a Bard being that I have
no real maybe
exhibitable skill other than being a
planner uh yeah insofar as I plan and
put people on different paths and
Adventures I would say that would be one
component where it is very DND like as
if when we're playing the game isn't
that right I mean I'll defer to the more
DND I think you never break the fourth
wall like if what you were trying to get
at is if is the style of the movie like
Jumanji no The Meta movie is going to be
the sequel and we get to know see
another side I mean you know that's very
interesting if if they decided to break
the fourth wall in within the game
playing system and put the players of
the game as the lead characters in the
next d d film I mean you'd be changing
the concept completely and we'd be out
of it and we'd be out of a job
um but you know I dig it I'm always
fascinated by multi-layer Worlds like
that
um we need to learn a little bit about
all your characters here so to not make
you give a basic description can you
each tell me what is their greatest
strength in their mission but then also
what's their greatest weakness the one
thing that could potentially do them in
when they're trying to get what they
want in the film
Simon's greatest strength is uh Simon
has a uh incomparable strength
uh magical strength like within him but
his weakness is that he has no idea how
to wield it uh because he is bogged down
with insecurity Simon's storyline is
very sad very tragic
that it brings it's the drama in the
film is Simon's storyline it is really
no I mean it has nothing to do if I've
got all that from watching you last
night I did I made you cry yes you did
he's marvelous in the film oh yeah oh
that's yeah
his strength is that he's uh very very
Charming very good at um making people
like him but his weakness is that
actually they all hate him he he has no
friends at all
yeah and he cares about having no
friends deep down yeah so it's awful for
him no one really loves him like a true
Rogue you say this like you have no hand
in why people don't like you in the
movie yeah you know like there's just no
reason for it it's nothing that the
Rogue has done or this happened in the
Rose Behavior oh I had a whole back this
morning I know I know there's a
backstory
what was it my mind
character strength and weakness okay
what you got character strength and
weakness um much like um in a job
interview my character's greatest
weakness is that he has no weaknesses
he's a little bit too he's very very
powerful and righteous and
straightforward and I think that he may
lack a certain empathy because of that I
think that there's such he's on such a
straight line of righteousness straight
lines straight line zinc
um in fact I think he he forgets that he
has much to learn still
[Music]
is a very difficult character to play in
the games he's like playing an NPC it's
he's a little bit right difficult and
unwieldy right I remember we played like
a cast d game I played him a lot like
Leroy Jenkins I just like plowed in and
it didn't go well for me I think holga's
greatest strength is her loyalty and I
think her greatest weakness would be her
hard-headedness I think my greatest
strength is I'm a positive good time
and uh my weaknesses are manifold
manifest uh they would probably be
selfishness
and cowardliness
toxic optimism
[Laughter]
that's a way to round it up that's funny
Ed Gonzalez was basically a Tinder
profile
strength I can um turn into animals and
weakness is um I'm surrounded by idiots
[Laughter]
so the trailer basically presents your
characters as like the starting point
the core right I'm curious for the three
of you where they fit into the group in
terms of how everybody else looks at
them like are they the smartest are they
the strongest are they the one that
nobody trusts as much how would you
describe their them in the group dynamic
our character yes I think uh holga and
Edgar based on like them being the
starting point at least as presented in
the trailer they seem fairly like clear
like the the leader or the men with the
plan
I'm such the right hand the characters
like she's like always falling in love
with all the wrong people he's always
making all the wrong plans some of the
best action sequences I've seen yeah
sure you're kind of perfect
you're mean well and you just need to
find yourself
um
yeah we should have asked someone else
to describe the other characters that
was the way to get it the brains the
brawn I thought you were the brains no
you're the brains I think you're the
smartest one out of all of us I think I
think Chris is the brain
he likes to think he's yeah yeah you're
the honor brains the brain the brawn the
honor and the beauty
that's what it is next question
coming your way I want some specifics in
terms of his his tactics as as a leader
of this place because he's a lord now
but he was a thief before so what does
it mean to be a thief turned Lord and
how he kind of rules his realm uh well
he's a con man
and um
yeah so it's that's a great asset for a
politician Justice for you so you've
worked with Jurassic Park dinosaurs
you've worked with Pokemon you're
working with a whole bunch of other
creatures in this movie right now
lizards all of them had giant lizards in
them okay of the bunch yeah that's
that's pretty which creature would you
say is the best scene partner and which
was the most difficult to work with I I
I think the most difficult was Jurassic
because it was we had some practical
dinosaurs on on that but in the first
one it was mostly tennis balls so I just
had to act like I was afraid of tennis
balls Pokemon
that was just a you know that's so fun
that's like a childhood dream come true
the Dragonborn creatures that would walk
around set um like they were practical
practically made and they would drool
there was so much attention to detail
and because I wasn't familiar with d d
before it helped me
further immerse in the world getting to
practically see oh this is what a uh
tabaxi looks like this is what a era
cobra looks like yours are so cool do
you have a favorite creature of the
bunch you know what those Dragon people
are awesome I don't know what you call
them in the DND world because I'm not
familiar with the terminology but dude
those guys just look a little Dragonborn
yeah Dragonborn Dragonborn oh my God
they're just so cool they
I remember doing a close-up I'm thinking
I'm rather good in this shot and then I
went to look at the monitor see if how
marvelous I'd been and you in the
background one of these bloody Dragon
things walks through the background of
the shot and you think what's that and
obviously no one's listening or looking
at me they're
upstaged by this creature
so I would have cut all those out
I can't let you all go
whisking the
can actually comment on this and what
you can
hear to continue this franchise and make
it a long-running film series
no I'm waiting to see how I was gonna
say yeah I'm like I hope so let me put
my producer hat on and give back to
someone say yes yeah hopefully yeah yeah
I believe I'd love to be a part of a
sequel I wouldn't mind working with you
guys again I love these guys you really
mean mad Sophia
look at that
that's not bad at all it's an immensely
vast world with Limitless opportunities
and I think that if people enjoy hanging
out in that world they'll probably have
an opportunity to do so again okay I'm
going to build on that really quickly
because I know a bunch of you have been
a part of franchises and sequels before
so what is something unique to Dungeons
and Dragons that will make it you know
and especially uh promising and really
fulfilling world to keep exploring
through the franchise format well I
think a lot of people don't know the
vast maps that are available like you
don't have to stay in the world that
we're in I forget what the name of our
map is do you remember it includes the
underdark it includes all of the uh you
know faerun and all of these different
locations that you'll see in this movie
but you're not isolated to that there
are gateways into other games that are
steampunk or you know you step into
other layers there's about like I think
I think she I was having a conversation
and it was about like five different
maps that that take you to different
style Worlds the sums in the future some
in the past some seeming ancient some
seeming very close to our current
culture and I I don't know I think that
there's many places to go with with with
with the worlds that are available yeah
the things about DND is that it's it's
there's so much a World building around
it that like you can try to learn as
much as you can about it but you you
can't because there's just they're still
making new worlds and they're still
making new characters and and new
creatures and
um you know players are making new
creatures and new worlds and it's just
constantly spreading this universe so um
uh yeah it's uh can go on forever the
real Joy of it is that it is immense
certainly the way that they've done this
movie it's immensely welcoming to people
who have absolutely no idea what
Dungeons and Dragons is my favorite
thing about the reactions I've seen to
people who've said it so far it's those
are like I have no idea what Dungeons
and Dragons is I don't know what any of
those creatures are called what any of
those spells are called but I had an
amazing time because it's just people
adventuring through this vastly
Fantastical magical world discovering
themselves is more important than doing
the math and roll in the dice it's it's
a little bit like the closest thing I
can think in my head is a bit like
watching The Impossible yes it's a super
movie but it's about the people in the
movie cool and it's kind of the same
feeling that I was getting off Dungeons
and Dragons from this and so it's a
great welcome mat into the world I
promise the next time I see you all I'll
stop being a self-conscious Outsider
looking in and I I will have played and
experienced it
congratulations I can't wait to see the
movie and to everybody out there tickets
are on sale now hurry up and get them